dad confronts teacher who made his son
wear a dress woke teacher is getting
called out number one
my grandson being in a dress I mean I'm
trying to see what the issue is director
is she the one that was in charge of the
kids while my grandsons
wow because you're not you're not a form
we'll have to get Dara up here and she
and she will let you okay that makes
sense not on the forums
because we don't do that the the uh the
transgender and all that we you know we
don't do that
I don't appreciate you encouraging him
to put on no drips exactly for the
second day too I don't appreciate that
yeah and don't think this is going away
I'm going further with this my kid is
not going to public school no I'm not
done talking to you I mean you know the
next time
if you put any kid in a dress we're
gonna make you go viral right you need
to show talk to my director there's a
cross hanging on the wall so this is
probably somebody that went to you know
Christian preschool where they thought
they were just going to be taught
perhaps some a little bit of religion
amongst you know Reading Writing and
arts and crafts they're breeding weak
men it's weird I don't know what again
we don't know the context maybe it was
like a big bucket of costumes and
everybody put on a costume and if a
little boy put on a dress because he
thought it was amusing it doesn't
necessarily mean that he wants to be a
girl or he's transgender like maybe the
kid just picked out that costume and put
it on to get a laugh like we don't know
I'm the teacher no how many you know I
got an issue with you about that
no I'm speaking to you please do not
talk to me in that tone with my children
I wouldn't be up here see that's the
problem right there these are not your
children these are your students there's
a big difference between somebody being
your child and being your student and
you should be Consulting with parents
before you implement your ideologies on
their children everybody doesn't believe
me don't even know I want people to
respect your views on certain things you
need to respect other people's views on
certain things and that means you need
to be talking and communicating with
people's parents if you plan on putting
their sons in dresses like that's wild
to me if you want to put my grandson in
no dress
well do what you got to do no I'm taking
up with you taking up a joke I'm taking
up with you well you shouldn't have put
my grandson what would you have done if
like my elementary school was putting me
in a dress you wouldn't have you
wouldn't have like what the [ __ ] you
guys doing I needed a note to watch Like
A P like a PG movie I'd have to bring in
a movie note I couldn't even take an
Advil at school you can't leave the
building until you're 18 years old like
during the school day I mean yeah I
would have thought it was weird
but I would have again it depends on the
context it really does and I but I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have even
thought of it here's the thing I would
have even thought of it as back then we
we weren't worried if a little kid if a
little boy put on a dress again it was
just for like amusement and or whatever
you just freaking felt like it or he I
don't know why a little boy won but it
really wasn't the first thing that you
thought of the first thing right the
first thing we thought of when you were
a little kid wasn't oh they're trying to
make them into a girl now it really is a
problem so I could see why this man
would would think that I want to know
what really happened here if this lady
is telling little boys why don't you try
in a dress and see how it feels to be a
girl today that's freaking weird and
ridiculous I agree with you it's right
over with all right at least she's going
off no questions because when I was in
school not that long ago it was the far
right trying to push religion into the
school system that was a part of the
problem now we've done a complete 180.
how about let's just stick to the math
and the science because as a taxpayer
when I send my kids to school I
shouldn't have to decide between q and I
conspiracy theories and gender identity
propaganda and I'm sure most teachers
are doing the best they can working with
what few resources they have trying to
educate their students in what appears
to be a crumbling Nation but just hear
me out when you allow teachers to dress
little boys up like little girls and
then you allow those same teachers to
have sexual conversations with children
you just might attract a certain kind of
person and it isn't a person that
aspires to be an astronaut y'all know
how we use euphemisms to make people
feel better about their jobs like
instead of calling people porn stars We
Now call them adult film actresses well
a criminal justice and sociology major
at ODU said instead of calling them
pedophiles we should call them minor
Attractive people yes
so much for that question
um I use the term minor attractive
person or math in the title and
throughout the book for multiple reasons
um first of all this person looks like a
pedophile it's important to use
terminology for groups that members of
that group want others no dude this is
[ __ ] so we're going to sit and forget
about the child abuse and focus on the
feelings of the abuser the minor
attracted person no you're a [ __ ]
creep a creep who should be castrated
this person can have your hands cut off
at the wrist this is a Droid person's in
The Sims it's for them
um and math advocacy groups like before
you act
pedophiles advocacy advocacy groups
primarily because it's less stigmatized
you should be stigmatized if you are a
pedophile you should be stigmatized this
is just like lunacy oh wait this is
Extreme far left like I'm not I don't
even like to base I'm a logical person
so I don't like to look at this and then
be like the whole left is nuts because
this is clearly off the Spectrum and
then like another couple miles down the
the world oh no this doesn't this isn't
a Democrat issue this isn't like
any Democrat and and think any normal
Democrats think that they believe this
because I know they don't so this is so
Fringe and we do have to yes you're
right I'm glad you said that this is so
Fringe this isn't normal and it's the
same thing what the left does with the
right they'll look at someone so crazy
and ALT right and then they'll be like
the whole right is racist and it messed
up and it's like no you know what I mean
yeah we can't right you can't you're
exactly can't just keep going after the
alts of each side because I don't do the
same thing for the left I look at this
as just like this person
look he looks like a bunny rabbit look
at this well that's that's not just
automatically
just stop and let's just take back in
that a lot of people think that the word
pedophile automatically assumes sex
offender so if you're a pedophile who
hasn't actually acted on those urges
you're just a minor attracted person
until when until you rape a little boy
or girl and then can we call you a
pedophile or are we still gonna call you
a minor attracted person because we
don't want to hurt your feelings it was
Jeffrey Dahmer a humavivore
oh is that a girl it might be a
transitioning girl who knows that is a
complete [ __ ] circus clown lunatic
whoever that is I'm sorry true and it
leads to a lot of miscarriage I just
wish that a giant fist would come onto
the screen and just knock this person
out while they're talking it doesn't
indicate anything about the morality of
that attraction the morality of the
attraction yes it does recently at the
State University of New York an Ethics
Professor by the name of Stefan
kirschner said that there shouldn't be
an age of consent now keep in mind this
next clip is two minutes and 30 seconds
so if you have the attention span of a
chicken sandwich it might be a little
tough for you bear with me because I
think it's important for you guys to
hear the whole thing imagine that an
adult male wants to have to a 12 year
old girl imagine that she's a willing
participant a very standard very widely
held view that there's something deeply
wrong about this and it's wrong
independent of it being criminalized
it's not funny to me that is even the
camera
and I think that exploring why it's a
mistake will tell us not only things
about adult child sex and stuff
but also about fundamental principles of
morality well there's a couple things to
say here one is even if you are looking
for a threshold let's say it just sounds
great but let's say it's at age eight
um still and that tells you that some
adult child is permissible
second the notion that it's wrong even
with a one-year-old
is not quite obvious to me there are
reports in some cultures of grandmothers
fellating their uh the baby boys to calm
them down when a colicky now I don't
know if it's true but what the [ __ ] did
he just say you know what he said
Grandma's giving no no no I'm done I'm
not widely reported as occurring in in
at least one culture and it working that
the grandmas believe but believe this
actually works
and people like him or anybody that had
any any uh scientific questions about
vaccines or any number of things got
banned this is a college professor
banned from social media
dangerous for Dangerous rhetoric and
this isn't dangerous no saying that
saying that it it's not morally wrong to
to molest or have sexual interactions
with babies
even
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] lunatic
he needs to have a [ __ ] bag thrown
over his head yeah cement shoes thrown
on him and thrown into the deepest
[ __ ] lake in America
so yeah I guess I think no I don't think
there's a blanket I think I'm joking
period Beyond I don't think it's just
permissible if we're interested in
willing participation I hope he doesn't
have kids structured it then yeah
there's a point below which people
aren't willing participants in anything
because they don't have intentions or
they don't have the sort of mental
states that allow for Willing
participation but no I don't I don't
think it's blanket wrong at any age
they might think that you know what I do
think is kind of annoying when people
take like the 18 like so literally so if
you're like 19 and there's a girl 17
who's like smoking hot it's like nah bro
that's a that's such a force it's like
bro 1917 like who gives a [ __ ] but you
still can't mess around with it because
her because even if she is willing and
but her parents find out that you
obsessed with her and they won't impress
charges they can even if she's like no
Mom and Dad we're in love and you know
they can press charges so you just I
think it goes a little bit deeper than
that but I I think that also people get
like too weird about the age thing and
I'm not saying to go out and have you
know do stuff with like young girls it's
not what I'm saying at all I just think
that people like sometimes take like
like because I'm a teenager so people my
age are like way too like oh I just
turned 18. she's 17 like oh that's
that's horrible like that like bro it's
not that it's not that [ __ ] crazy
okay they're willing Christmas the
voluntary participants they have some
understanding what's going on not
understanding we do but some
understanding but they haven't consented
but perhaps that's so but that's a
different claim from there being
unwilling there's lots of activities the
children engagement that they don't
we're just not non-consent have to do
with people when you first make sure
you're not in Focus
or you prepare for your your Bat Mitzvah
a rough idea but not clear how much
before we understand
what I am saying
instead of indoctrinated you're just
this guy like calling regular Americans
conspiracy theorists or right-wing nuts
because they want to know what their
kids are learning in school and again
just so that I'm clear I'm not saying
that this is a majority I understand
that this is a small minority but when
you sedate Boys by giving them opioids
because they can't sit still for eight
hours I don't know what five-year-old's
able to do that anyway but when you
sedate boys because they can't sit still
for eight hours straight you put them in
dresses and then you allow adults to
have sexual conversations with them
you're going to attract a certain things
so today in Virginia there were protests
um I don't know if it was in Fairfax
County it doesn't matter protesting
Governor Jenkins laws about parental
rights oh this is regarding education
I'll subscribe yeah give them a sub poor
man podcast reacts I like this yeah okay
so so there were protests today actual
people there protesting parental rights
because they believe that it's it's
racist and anti and homophobic and
transphobic and all those things for
parents to know what's being taught in
school and having a say give me a break
we pay to bills we pay the taxes we
should have a say we're the ones raising
our children we're supposed to be
sending them to school to learn Reading
Writing arithmetic life skills not your
morality not what the government wants
to train them in I was talking to a dear
friend about the don't say gay law and
uh in Florida and Ron DeSantis it has
been all over the news this year that's
the governor of Florida because he put a
law into a place that said that um from
up until third grade there will be no
curriculum in Florida that covers uh
sexual orientation or gender
identification none because they believe
that up until the age of nine or ten
children don't understand it they don't
need to learn it it's inappropriate to
talk about anything that involves sex
and attraction and those kinds of things
I don't think that's unreasonable but
what the leftist media did is they
called it the don't say gay law and they
turned it into this big hoopla
that they're anti-gay and Governor Ron
DeSantis is the devil and all this so
the word gay doesn't even appear in the
uh in the bill at all the words
um sexual orientation and gender
identity are not even in are in the bill
twice and I just want to read this one
sentence from the bill because when you
hear these catchphrases this is the
don't say gay law you have to look
deeper I tell people read the bill did
you read the bill no
what are you mad about you're mad
because the talking head on TV told you
to be mad look deeper go in okay
classroom instruction by school
Personnel or third parties on sexual
orientation or gender identity may not
occur in kindergarten through grade
three or in a manner that is not
age-appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in accordance
with state standards
that's what they're hanging this guy
trying to hang this guy in a cross for
because these are Republican and he
doesn't want little kids to be taught
about sex so he's assistant
he's a sicker who hates everybody who
deserves to die he deserves to die he
deserves to lose his office be put in
jail
[Music]